you
okay ten seconds until kickoff this is a
thirty second tournament this might be a
first in a last I'll give it a shot
though try it at least once at least
once a lot of pre moves will be
necessary
you gotta go quick trying to kill me on
c2 already shame on them shame on them
did I even say that right okay take up
the pawn double isolated pawns I should
have waited until taking but I don't
have time for weeding out those little
those little details
it's weasel around here throw this guy
up you have pawn space invader bishops
trapped how about that I can take
someone down with them it's a freebie
I'm on step 7 thorn I'd have taken just
anything just don't get made it anything
time burners okay they're down the time
back to tournament it's gonna be a lot
of that hopefully for me
you gather down on time back to
tournament Primo's free moves are you
gonna move notes
fast not so fast I have the bishop pair
slow down man [ __ ] Oh easy does it
yeah that's a great strategy easy does
it easy does it
there's a fork there's a fork it doesn't
matter though it really doesn't
Queen trade mother night flight square
get rid of the night take with the Queen
who they could have taken back why
didn't they take the rook look the
exchange here come on man
free moves Bishop d4 don't do that
whatever you do don't do that time
bankers run with the pawn give some
checks rattle the King position get your
can out hang on they're down on time
back determine oh yeah that's just how
it is man thirty Seconds what do you do
when you only have 30 seconds go four
quick kills go for very quick kills okay
take towards the center h2 okay let's
take care and anchor my night hmm just
trying to do that because of me a
problem though play f6 soon okay it
feels like they're close to losing some
material they're um mass exchanges I
guess I want to keep some more material
on the board aha
sneak attack trade okay
should be able to get this without issue
back determine acquiring positions where
you can pre move out the rest of the
game is super important these are the
kind of strategies you have to go for
just help their queen develop light on
you why don't you do that more often why
not okay grant my knight a home on e5
with that fork of f4 and the Queen give
some material but you have this with
check not quite getting the rook the
knight defends the rook bishops a beast
you've gone as far as you're going to go
let's get rid of him okay oh not cool
not cool what I just did there I have to
sack the exchange let's go here my king
could run like the wind blows
yikes oh no there goes the exchange they
didn't take that wild pawn hmm and I'm
not to say what do you let me say how
much time do I have I can't move I can't
move I can't move oh that was awful ah
you know that happened in one of the
other earlier tournaments my opponent I
just allowed their pawn to run wild go
down promote and start checking me like
crazy like crazy stop their silly pawn
man and then have some fun of your own
with your own queen man ah yeah this
guy's just frustrated again that's all
that's all he's just frustrated yeah
keep a knight in the center take with
check open up the h-file I didn't see
that they just moved Castle queenside
probably no matter what go here quite
sure why
break in the center remove recaptures
double grab that palm there's no whose
move is it whose move is it oh man I
messed up I messed up I didn't realize
what does that move do what does this
move till um yeah I don't have much time
man
time burner they're down on time
ridiculous yeah I know I know many of
you left it is ridiculous I agree it's a
mouse race this isn't chess it's just a
mouse race I'm not watching this I feel
you man I feel you I understand I
understand I really do you're just gonna
have to believe me I understand
Oh
grab a phone play here and then there
and look for h7 never see it coming
let's check check check
don't repeat a check there are we close
to me Oh clay Castle or pieces needed I
think he's a runner he's a running King
is it mate yet is he yet I'm not sure
what that does you could take a night if
you want that's Queen that's a night my
night is gonna be the one he's the one
who's finally gonna do it yes well done
night well done that was a crazy crazy
crazy King sixteen fifteen fourteen
fourteen on a 12 the Ferraris in there
he's fantastic with joining late and
being a sneek artist break up the center
pawn duo's are dangerous okay building
center with d5 give their knight a kick
keep pushing forward
central majority good things happen
play here here if allowed over there Oh
drop my bishop that's alright where's
their King side development gone
non-existent Forks discoveries that
wasn't a fork there's a queen
alright there's a rook here they're here
no matter what recapture here no matter
what get the bishop that mate yet close
to me close to me very close to me is
the night going to do the trick one of
these two finally back to tournament man
twenty eighteen eighteen sixteen sixteen
well these games are flying flying quick
hell I got tried at least once at least
once kill your Bishop why don't you trap
them trap your Bishop that's alright
though it took it took them two seconds
to figure out they could get that piece
ah I got their Queen in the process okay
watch out for G 7 g7 alert break up in
the F file okay throw my knight here I
guess now e 6 okay take on f6 alright
gotta watch out for their sneak attacks
I need some some air some air check not
there where's the checks no not there
not there here come on you should be
really good with giving checks you have
a clean man you have a queen you have a
queen man
ah oh no stalemate Oh
are you hearing my mouse he's going wild
he's going wild oh it's so difficult
it's so difficult when they have a queen
and they could just keep moving like
that ah man
how'd I let that happen why did I allow
my queen to get taken by their silly
rook man okay you got a focus you got a
phone
yeah oh my goodness what am i doing man
what am i doing
so the Ferrari you're dropping upon
you're dropping upon and stuff man
I'm dropping a rook yep
just gonna oh they already moved not a
good sign I don't want a castle nope
let's throw the H pawn break down there
dark squares holy cow
take flying Wow um Wow
gotta go much faster Wow I'm not to say
this good grief I got it finally oh my
goodness was that a crazy crazy crazy
King again it's not the first time I'm
saying that how's the commentary on that
one brilliant brilliant I think I said a
lot of educational things in that one
favorite that favorite that game oh oh
man yes yes oh holy cow holy cow Batman
holy cow Batman okay the Kings gonna be
a fighter pre move like a wild wild guy
oh man that was a free rook don't have
time to take exchanges though you don't
have time to take exchanges better King
position look what I'm playing for King
position that's position on this
position illness all right I gotta go
over here trade man trade oh can I get
this guy that guy and then push here
okay Queen hopefully this guy is not
like pehoe vaq and a genius with dodging
checks keep going how's the clock
actually quite good on my end back to
term and holy cow oh oh watch out for
the sniffles 31 25 21 21 what do I have
20 call it we're not even at the halfway
point can you believe it it's the Smith
Morra gambit I know just what I know
just what to do against these yes take
him he's free he really is oh look at
this
look at this yeah doing that's a freebie
take there tonight
dark square bishop do something good
bishops roof deadly move the rook take
that guy return return some more back
here defend defend open up this get the
Queen hit the night kill the night Queen
trade incoming we're doing good on the
clock more trades hang on hang on stop
there pawn you've had that happen before
I just get too focused stop pushing my
own pawns and I'm saying I like you know
what you could just push your pawn to uh
get your own Queen and I'm okay with
that no I'm not okay with that anymore
no more Queens stop there Queens and get
Queens for you
thirty-eight I can't breathe I just
can't ever breathe
I could never breathe against this guy
there take that he's free there we go
all right let's let's let's do the Greek
gift the Greek gift the Greek gift this
will get them thinking this is already
mate on the clock I mean now I want to
keep the Queens on the board Forks so
check another check maybe here never see
that coming here they're here time
burning stuff oh no oh I have to watch
out for g2 are you kidding me oh no
that's mate oh man
a delayed reaction oh I had their King
on the ropes on the ropes man just hit
them with all you didn't even need a
haymaker man just a little jab like
right in the gut just a little jab
jab and that was it ah man and there is
he's off and running 42 you left you in
the dust man I thought I was doing good
man on the clock
I had him rocked back but he fought back
like a genius like a genius Oh too
intense too intense there does your C
pun oh okay we got expand we have a
space advantage there night I'm sacking
cannot deal with the night I thought he
was going to go into e3 pigs don't block
with the rook rook rook was in a play
there that night scaring me he's really
scaring me gotta go up with the king
keep going got it throwing some checks I
should go for a trade because I have
this majority I have a majority over
here keep going
free moves
okay keep going man
keep going you could do it you could do
it you could do it run over here run
around the King run around the King know
stalemates know stalemates know
stalemates mate
finally point one point two collet 4228
26 26 I'm at 26 it's a race for a second
Ferrari shame on you man shame on you
shame on you sorry sorry I don't have
time I don't have time those sniffles
will get the best of you don't know what
it means I don't know what it means
I really don't hear they're they're
killing me on the clock here oh yeah
just drop you six the Queen okay
let's blast this open then okay
LightSquared bishop do something
dangerous man do something dangerous
they moved not seeing that my opponents
are moving now cool they're down on time
okay
take oh I got to do a break sneak attack
I here get rid of the night
sneaky King back to tournament Wow
Ferrari lost 44 31 29 28 28 huh 11
minutes remain okay alrighty
uh yeah am I gonna get paired up with
there's John Madden now let's get f/4 in
the mix slow down man you have to go so
fast oh you sneaky sneaky Queen grabbing
the F pawn grabbing the F fun should
never be able to survive that never okay
Oh dangers man danger it's dangerous
it's dangerous on f7 um over here checks
no I just dropped the knight defend just
kill the knight he's no good man time
burners Queen trade check crop into a
ball they're down a time I might try
that next time I give a check and then
crawl up into a ball
oh okay play this guy many times now I
get this guy yes Queens off threatening
a fork on c2 okay let's get rid of him
and here maybe damage their structure
let's try that my knight into f4 okay
he's going to be intolerable get the
King towards the center okay this isn't
cool let's throw in a check first and
then take the pawn I got to hunt this
pawn down I'm not sure where I should go
with my King towards the center now I
know trade now I shouldn't have done
that let's keep the rook on the board
Oh take care how's the clock on my side
actually throw the King in the corner
stop there pawn take their pawn no
stalemates man no stalemates back to
tournament holy cow holy cow this is
fast 48 36 33 less than 8 minutes remain
home my goodness
I mean I've played this before and that
very little experience first time doing
it with couch here throw the F bone Adam
let's throw the F bond Adam take my pawn
yeah let's do that
hey they don't like to castle they don't
like to castle I I see I see that they
do not like to castle um ok
they like to stop me from castling
though that much is clear
yeah they're really good with stirring
up some trouble yep yeah I should have
done that one move sooner clean trade uh
move your king man move your king Oh
oh my god holy cow that's a lot of moves
man oh my goodness 63 moves in that one
he's running away
56:36 35 35 oh wow
Wow oh okay
that was craziness again it's not gonna
change
oh it's not gonna change okay it's a
race for a second who's gonna get it
who's gonna get it oh man
who is going to get it here oh that was
a mouse Lipper um get rid of their night
he's super valuable keep the night on
the board man keep the night on the
board they're going to expect to check
fake them right out check
I'll be doing on the clock man holy cow
yeah what do you want me to talk about
man what do you want me to talk about I
should make sure to title this one
speech as tournament without commentary
without commentary uh 60 38 36 35 maybe
I should bruiser --k why not why not no
don't get too crazy 60 38 36 35 35 yes
it's a giant giant giant race for a
second look at everybody except for the
first-place guy hmm
quick kill yes hang on for a second
60/40 36 35 keep you in check
keep your opponents in check keep them
on their toes in other words scholars
mate watch out for it it gets you as a
Scholastic player and as a master oh my
goodness
free night but it took a half a second
to take him I don't know if it was
worthwhile
okay Queen trade avoided I insist I
insist take their how to take back up
get to the file actually you didn't need
to back up just hang your rock hang your
ruck one Lea open okay where's your
queen gun right here duck and cover
don't play b4 oh no oh they locked it
down 11 seconds each
and that's supposed to be up like a
piece here take the pawn with check uh
here have this guy let's check clean
trade Bishop check they're not going to
see that one coming back to Turman holy
cow 7244 why do I always get white not
complaining just wondering I'm not
saying I get an advantage you from
playing black don't take a like that
yeah the results just gonna be the same
in doesn't matter what call you play
quit your crying quit your crying
play better chess how about that play
better chess quit your crying and play
better chess okay they're getting up on
back they're getting their pawn back oh
I think I'm doing all right on the clock
that did not help me at all alright
break down their light squares man break
down their light squares take that guy
King position King position they're
sneaky they are so sneaky
all right what do you want to say what
do I say huh I don't know what to say
hopefully
Oh wily man they're Wiley Wiley man
they're like the roadrunner the
roadrunner 74 46 ah my time on get
second I think yeah I should be able to
get second man even when you have a
queen even when you have a queen doesn't
matter it doesn't matter yeah yeah what
do you want me to say what do you were
really what are you here what are you
here for are you waiting for me to say
something there's nothing good
commentary wise to come of this chapter
clean she does she's not needed
she is not needed all you need in this
variant is a tricky night and he's gone
you just dropped him there's a fork you
hang on the material you're gonna need
it you're gonna need it you're lacking
some material you're lacking some
material tricky nights you can't rely on
any color complex with the tricky night
he's still around the night is still
around down on time back to tournament
Wow Wow oh man 74 46 43 40
Wow I need to take a break good games
all man who took part in this one I
wasn't the only crazy one to take part
in this one there were 55 others let's
see them page 2 3 4 5 6
Wow hats off if you took part in this
man and completed it crazy crazy crazy